why do you think people in Russia love
him so much what is it about him that
people in Russia love in Russia it's
like if you have very small things
people happen I don't know like where
I'm from like from dagistan and from
dagistan we don't need too much then ask
me brother why you never ask me how much
I'm going to pay you to come
back said brother doesn't matter even if
you give $ 100 million it doesn't matter
for me you know why because I'm from
dagistan and we have traditional and we
have uh when we talk with our mothers
it's everything for us this is
everything like I was talk with my
mother we make decision we make the plan
it was it's going to be my last fight
like
finish it's uh it's hard
question but we completely different
people I think